From literature to plays and movies around the world,
Human obsession with love is strongly our obsession with broken heart / heartbreak.
But is heart fracture simply a simple concept, or does it have a real effect on the body and brain?
Whenever you experience physical pain, such as injury or injury, the frontal cortex stimulates.
Surprisingly, it is the same area of ​​the brain that is activated when you feel you've lost or lost a social relationship.
Perhaps physical pain and emotional pain are not as different as we thought before.
Think about the ways in which love is missing ...
"I tore my heart," "It was like a slap on the face," "I am emotionally wounded."
This use of physical description
It draws a clear relationship, at least in language, between emotional and physical pain.
In fact, studies have shown that humans prefer
To be physically hurt to feel socially excluded.
But why these two different experiences
Do you feel the same feeling in our bodies?
Obviously our bodies are using physical pain to prevent
Threat any imminent danger.
But, from an evolutionary point of view,
Anything that increases our overall survival and physical fitness as a family
Are likely to continue.
And the formation of relationships and social ties between lovers and friends alike
Has become an important part of the survival of many factions.
You are paying attention to me, and I will pay attention to you.
Just like your desire not to burn by hot coffee again,
Animals do not want to be socially alone.
The pain of both cases increases our chances of survival
By avoiding unwanted results.
You have chances to survive and reproduce
If you are not alone.
This can be seen in monkey studies
Which when separated from the one you love,
Her body is experiencing an increase in cortisol
A decrease in the secretion of Norepinephrine,
Causing a high response to stress.
Eventually, this led to depression, anxiety, and closer crying out loud.
For humans, separation, a family member is lost, or isolation
Can lead to a similar reaction,
Create a sense of physical pain.
So, how can we alleviate this pain?
Especially as the plasters and creams are dedicated to physical wounds!
Studies have shown that high levels of social support
Associated with low levels of pain,
While socially isolated individuals show little recovery
So if you feel a broken heart,
Surround yourself with friends and family,
Despite this difficulty ..
If someone you know is suffering emotionally,
He was next to him to provide social support.
Because scientifically - we humans - we all just want to belong somewhere.
This episode of AsapScience is supported by Audible.com,
And the leading supplier
For audio books with more than 150,000 downloadable titles
In all kinds of literature.
If you want to learn more about the brain,
Read the book "Thinking, Fast and Slow" by Daniel Kaneman.
You can also download these audio books
Or else of your choice for free at audible.com/asap.
Special thanks to audible
To make these videos possible
You are provided a free clip at audible.com/asap.